your Emmy campaign has been pretty
intense like it's it's clear that you're
you're really going for it this year I
don't know what are you serious I don't
know what you're talking about I'm not
you know what you're doing I don't
campaign for hello you're here hello oh
the Emmys are coming up nice no no I
know you like coming here but yes you've
been full throttle Emmy campaign you
come on people do it and you've been
doing well what are you talking about I
yesterday 2 o'clock in the morning I'm
at a magazine stand in Hollywood and
you're doing it a magazine not important
Who I am not important my business
that's not what we're talking about now
when I come on your show we'll talk
about him /her
my point is that I don't say it's just
your mat your your puss is on every
cover you you have done so many your
Matthieu so many magazine covers to get
an Emmy I mean it's fine I don't do that
what that what is this what is this
right here I bought this one you're on
the cover of stank magazine
what's that
my publicist said that would be good the
kids read it what's what the hair that's
my hair if I take this everybody take
this piece off at night that's okay yeah
what about this magazine I picked this
one up Oh serious actor magazine that
was an incredible honor
you look like an angry old woman well
with the wig on back look I just that's
how you prepare for any role you you
have to comb your hair like that and
yeah yeah I don't know it looks like
you're doing every single magazine look
at this right here
European fella magazine honing that now
that
yes this that's you and I yes we did
this together yes few weeks ago we were
doing that event what was it I don't
remember what was it it was a charity
event it was a charity event yeah cuz
pancakes oh that's right yes you're
right we were making cooking pancakes
for the homeless I remember that yeah it
was a celebrity thing I've never seen
two bigger douchebags in my life get
paid on that bob odenkirk would you like
a pancake
you